-Sarah, how are you?
-Hi. Good.
Yeah. Thanks.
How you doing?
-I'm doing well.
This is the longest-distance
interview
we have done since
social distancing started.
You're in Australia right now.
Thank you for waking up
so early to do this.
-I am, I am.
It's not too bad.
It's like 9:00 a.m.
It's fine.
It's a regular workday.
-It is a regular workday.
And I should --
I want to congratulate you
for your Emmy nomination
for "Succession," but because of
the time difference,
that must have happened in the
middle of the night for you.
Are you the kind of person
who sets an alarm
to find out if this happened?
-No.
[ Laughs ] No.
I totally --
My manager asked
if I wanted to be woken up,
I was like, "No.
It's like 2:00 in the morning.
I'll sleep. Either I've been
nominated or I haven't.
It's not gonna change
whether I wake up or not."
No, I got woken up by my friend
who I'm living with
at the moment in lockdown.
And they ran into the room
and pulled the pillow
off my head and said, "You've
been nominated for an Emmy!"
And, yeah, it was a pretty
good way to find out.
-That's a great way to find out.
You know, I was talking to --
Matthew Macfadyen
was on the show.
He obviously is fantastic
playing your husband, Tom.
And he was saying one of
the disappointing things,
the depressing things, one
of the many depressing things,
but you guys won't be able
to celebrate together
at a virtual Emmys.
Is that a bummer?
-Yeah, it is.
It is, because I miss everybody.
And, you know,
I want to be working again.
And everyone's in the same boat,
globally,
no matter the industry.
Everyone wants
to get back to work,
to be social
and with their friends.
But I feel like
we've got such a great team
and have such a great chemistry
on and off screen that,
yeah, it's a shame not to be
able to do that all together,
particularly for so many of us
being nominated at the Emmys.
It's -- It's wild.
-I also want to point out that I
was lucky enough to meet you
last year, like,
the night-before party.
And the whole "Succession" cast,
not just yourself
but all of you,
you guys were like
the hot people
that everybody
wanted to talk to.
-[ Laughing ]
-Everybody wanted to come up --
'Cause I felt like, right as
the Emmys was hitting last year
was when everyone had finally
caught up to the show.
It was cresting
just at the right time.
-It was pretty, in some ways,
confronting, I guess, for me,
because I really didn't expect
to go to the Emmys last year
and, like, slip under the radar,
not be seen,
just work out
what it's all about.
"Okay,
that's a very famous person,
there's another one,
I'm from Australia,
just be cool, chill out."
But then, when they all started
coming up to me and going,
"Hey, I love your work!"
yeah, that -- [ Laughs ]
-I do feel like now everybody
is thirsting for a third season,
whereas the second season
maybe caught people
a little by surprise.
Obviously, you're thirsting
for a third season, as well.
Is there --
I mean, you hear whispers
that it's maybe
gonna start in the winter?
-Uh...yes?
I mean, I want to get back
as soon as possible.
And in a couple months' time,
that will happen.
But I think everything changes
so fast at the moment
that you can say it's October,
and it'll end up being
sometime later because,
you know,
we don't know.
-It's good that you guys,
as a cast,
are taking
the pandemic seriously,
because I don't think a single
character on the show would.
-No.
Well, only in the way of, like,
constantly hand-sanitizing
and just isolating themselves
way ahead of any advice
to isolate.
You know, and they've got
their summer palace.
They wouldn't even have
to isolate together.
They could all have a house
or a ranch to themselves.
Yeah, but they probably would
want to isolate together
in some ways just in case
somebody made some moves
or positioning.
-Right.
Just to keep eyes on them.
Has the show
taken off in Australia?
Because some might even say
it's based on Australians.
-It has taken off in a way
that I feel it's still, like,
what first season was
in America.
Like, there's still a bit
of word of mouth going on.
It's on a TV channel --
Like, it's on Foxtel
and on Binge now, I think.
So, it's -- it's there.
But it's still simmering,
which is nice. Yeah.
-You did find out on Halloween
that it was
slightly more popular
than you had known.
-[ Laughing ] I did, yes.
I keep getting tagged
in photographs that sort of
jarred me a little, to go,
"Oh, that's not me.
That's not me. That's a --
That's a terrible red wig.
But it's meant to be me.
Okay.
That's just paper-bag pants and
a turtleneck with a gold chain.
That's "you didn't know you
would be going to this
Halloween party
and you just found that
in your closet
and you made a costume."
My favorite was --
-But it was funny to hear that
and realize, "Oh, yeah,
Shiv does have a very
iconic style that you could
also not have to do
a ton of planning for
but also nail the Shiv look.
But this is a style you sort of
brought to the character, yes?
-Yes. I mean,
I wear high-waisted pants
and sort of a wider-leg pant,
I guess.
But there's no way in which
I am stylish as Sarah.
[ Both laugh ]
Any style I brought
to the character
was cherry-picked
from other things
and put together by Michelle
far more than it was me.
Yeah.
-I do want to provide you
this opportunity, before we go,
to clear up an Internet rumor
about your birthday.
-[ Laughing ] Oh, yes.
Please.
I'm a proud Sagittarian.
I am not born July 28th.
My birthday's
the 1st of December.
Someone made
a Wikipedia page up for me,
and they just decided
that 28th of July was me.
And so,
for a couple of years now,
I've been getting happy
unbirthdays from friends.
And even my agent actually
wished me a happy birthday once
a couple years ago.
-It's nice, though.
I feel like it's a good way
to distinguish your real friends
from your friends
who just sort of
are living off Internet
knowledge of you.
-Oh, 100%.
Yeah.
When I get a happy birthday from
someone who's maybe not
in the know, I'm like, "Okay.
Well, we need to work
on this friendship.
I need to let you in
a little closer.
Maybe it's my fault
that I haven't told you
my birthday is December the 1st.
-That's very helpful.
I'm thinking of planting
a poison pill
fake birthday myself now
on my Internet page,
just so I can separate
the posers from the real deal.
-Yeah. I mean, it's lucky
that I'm only six months out.
But I feel like, if I was gonna
fake my own birthday,
I should've gone, you know,
three, four years,
five years earlier.
-Yeah, that's true.
That's, I guess,
how we know you didn't do it.
-Yeah, it's true.
Yeah. Yeah.
-Congratulations again
on the nomination.
Thank you.
Again, it's 9:00 a.m.,
but for a lot of actors,
that's a big deal.
So we will say thank you.
And, uh...
-I'm going back to bed,
to be honest.
[ Both laugh ]
-Always great to see you, Sarah.
-Good to see you.